seri jean michel après une liposuccion
ou en tunisie
ce week end et oui l'opération a duré
une heure et demie on lui a retiré cinq
litres de graisse dans l'eau entre l'art
et pectoraux les poignées d'amour et le
bas du dos ces litres de graisse vous
pouvez les retrouver sur le banc je vous
le dis donc allez-y faites monter les
enchères n'hésitez pas les chéris alors
mais c'est vrai que vous normalement je
vous le dis il faut quelques jours de
vacances et quelques jours de repos pour
se remettre d'une telle opération
vous vous êtes déjà en plâtre avant
alors il ya deux solutions vous êtes un
vrai bosseur vous avez besoin d'argent
j'avais branches sauf que la douleur
n'est pas suffisante pour pas les bosses
et voilà
[Applaudissements]
on attend maintenant tu travailles pas
l'ami d'un bon train sejdiu la lusine
c'est un plaisir donc c'est plus appeler
à l'union vous avez tous lipow l'ifo
film et non donc vous êtes arrivé
c'était moi en tunisie c'était à tunis
même dans le centre de tunis aux lacs
bon d'accord au lac de tunis
donc c'était quoi en fait c'était ma
croûte des liposuccions makrouds un
ancien gay et qui sait comment s'est
passé j'ai tout fait mais vous avez pas
eu fraude parce qu'il vous m un tuyau
comme ça j'ai pas de targé pas tabou
avec la chirurgie esthétique donc ils
m'ont prouvé ils m'ont fait une
proposition ils m'ont dit vous payez pas
l'opération et en échange ça permet de
démocratiser au film opération est comme
ça on est malade on voit ça semblait pas
payer l'opération s'est payé le voyage
c'est bien de le dire j'ai payé j'ai
payé le voyage du pape et l'opération
donc le 20h c'est quoi c'est l'avion je
suis en avion c'était plus pratique
bonjour
alors on va voir les images c'est très
drôle michel jean michel vous êtes
phélippeau sucer l'oignon aussi au mois
de janvier dans le pied a donc fait les
frais au mois de janvier le traîner non
label hip hop us et l'oignon je me
serais retiré l'oignon coupé passer un
oignon sais pas c'est pas panaris c'est
lorsqu'il faut raboter alors remettre
les visites le fonds devrait donc tu vas
mettre tout y est comme à son bar à
bouteilles éloignez vous allez faire
quoi après une chute à zatta j d'art et
on verra bien je l'enverrai battre et ça
me fait plaisir vous êtes entre lui et
je sais pas ce qu'il a un mais il va
faire rôtir ailun fetwa nice effet les
peaux sujet il serge a rajouté des
cheveux il a dit hostile les paupières
elle est en train de s'exprimer pour
2020 et pour être au top à mon avis vous
allez devoir trouver quelque chose est
en train de chercher quelqu'un je fait
longtemps que je cherche mais l'aja
j'accélère là vous avez envie de trouver
un chemin j'ai envie de me donner les
moyens on serrait alors on regarde
regarde et l'opération je suis une fois
j'espère que ça sera visible voilà vous
aurez toutes les informations
je vous embrasse roger bientôt partir
d'un moment des faits et des scalpels
maison
où
[Musique]
bon les amis on est samedi en fin
d'après midi qui fut simple opération
j'ai été opéré hier en début d'après
midi
franchement je vois déjà le résultat de
ouf habite fait comme ça
bon maintenant je fais attention je fais
du sport gmail est monté à la fois la
laisse manger un petit couscous poulet
merguez que l'on peut dire que j'ai déjà
l'appétit et la forme que vous auriez dû
faire ça vous auriez dû vous fini avant
ouais j'suis les photos avant mais c'est
quoi cette photo je prends des photos
avant/après d'accord et pour les
locutions vous allez faire quoi la
matière ont donc évidemment beaucoup de
tunisiens qui m'ont dit là c'est très
sérieux que depuis notre passage en
tunisie est pas notre passage qu'on le
prenne la tunisie le tourisme a grimpé
en flèche mais ce n'est pas une
plaisanterie que les deux autres les
hôtels étaient tous bouquet foule cet
été et qu'il vous tous vous remercier
là-bas en l'air à partir le tourisme en
tunisie et fait même ceux qui me l'ont
dit ma mère